[Music]
jaquail night is the creative mind
behind many of Beyonce's iconic
performances he's worked with her for
years and he's been dancing his entire
life I remember dancing in my
grandmother's living room and then when
I was 16 I started my own dance group
with my best friend in Atlanta and I was
kind of the first serious step towards
choreography and creative direction at
just 18 jaquail landed a gig
choreographing best videos of all time
single ladies years later to quell
reveals what it takes to be a backup
dancer for Beyonce as a dancer it takes
every you know she's a southern girl you
know who's worked very hard to get where
she is
so she want people to do the same you
know she want to know that you want it
really bad she want to see your heart
and passion the drive and then you know
you got to be able to jam you know how
greasy can you get how how can you hit
it hard you know then there's also some
print that's looking for the technical
elements you know are you trained do you
have any ballet training you having a
jazz training
how are you lunch you know so it's a few
things that go into the process and once
we start to audition things you know we
look for everything we teach them
hip-hop nothing we see some of the super
difficult technical number we teach them
the classic Beyonce number you know and
then besides that you know you got to be
able to carry the stage you know with
her you know you got to be able to stand
next to her and be just as good you know
and sometimes people are ready sometimes
or not you could be a great dancer but
it may not come through when you get on
stage you know may kind of pull into a
shell don't know to look at it so she's
looking for stars star dancers who have
magic that can't break it you know and
pull the people in always working with
the during the rehearsal process is like
it's kind of out of body experience you
know people who don't earn this
and the amount of effort our work ethic
is out of this world and has never just
one thing you know when recreating a
choreography is okay boom where it's
wardrobe add you know bring the man so
they can see what the choreography is
okay boom where are we on the stage you
know let's make sure lighting knows how
to like this boom where are the cameras
okay let's look at this cover and then
do this you know we're always thinking
of every single piece of the puzzle but
you know in the end of the day we send
her pictures we send her videos she's
watching people in rehearsal like who's
that okay that's something we talked
about she's like okay she's good you
know she's looking at everything at
every moment you know so she's like
heavenly
[Music]